Talking about pounding and the Cantos
last week I was talking about translation
a lot. Uh, in the case of Elliot, uh,
I'll be talking about quotation,
a related but different practice.
Uh,
and one that we'll see
again, uh, in Marianne Moore,
uh,
impounds case,
there is,
uh,
a wish in poetry for immediacy for some
kind of seemingly natural language.
Pound doesn't want and doesn't use
quotation marks just as he doesn't use
footnotes. If you, um, if you
look at pound in any of the,
uh, additions of his
work from the Cantos, uh,
uh, backward, you will find that
the high, uh, uh,
you will find that the, uh, uh,
the poems are presented without notes,
without any kind of apparatus,
without any kind of help.
Uh, that's because I think,
um,
pound once to in some
sense give you a kind of,
he doesn't want to get
in your way in any sense.
He wants you to have a kind of immediate
experience of the writing that he's, uh,
uh, presenting, uh, even, uh, uh,
when it comes in the form of quotation.
Uh,
but as I suggested a for,
for Pan,
that sort of central practice,
uh, is one of, uh, translation,
which he also describes
as transmitting the,
the impulse. Uh, I and I, I spoke, uh,
last time as if the impulse meant,
uh,
the motive or the emotion, uh, in, uh,
a piece of writing.
I think that pound also had a kind of
scientific or technical sense of that,
that process of transmitting the impulse,
uh,
and that what he wants
to do is, uh, carry,
uh, you want, he wants
writing to carry energy. Uh,
he wants it to carry a kind of pulse,
uh,
and he wants to give you a
kind of direct access to this.
Uh, the, uh, contrast
with Elliot is a striking,
I think, uh, instead of, uh, translation,
you find an Elliot more often quotation,
quotation, um, uh,
which implies a certain
relation to the literary past,
just as pounds practices of translation
imply in relation to tradition.
I think about the difference
between these, these forums,
translation and quotation.
It's a way to understand the differences
between Elliot and pound, uh,
and through them, uh, to
think about modern Po,
at least two of modern poetry is possible.
Relations to the literature of the past.
Remember too, that modern
poetry, uh, and that's,
that's a word or a phrase
that Elliot and Pam both used,
that modern poetry is a
specifically historical category.
Uh, it's, you know, it's a historical
way of naming what it is. A,
you could contrast this with
the, uh, romantic poetry, say,
um, or images him. Um, yeah,
which are names or labels that identify,
um, a Oh, uh, uh, something more like, um,
a, an aesthetic project or a, a, a, um,
uh, uh, a tendency, uh, here, uh,
to call a modern poetry modern is
to choose as it's defining quality,
uh,
its position in history.
It's a place, uh, in literary history
and it does
place modern poetry in history.
Ambiguously
is modern poetry is, it
is, it's modernness, uh,
an index of,
um,
the way it extends the past or
is it rather modern because
it breaks with the past?
Does modern mean some kind of
renewal and continuity? Uh,
or more does it, uh, does it mean rupture
a translation in quotation
suggest? Uh, well, as I say,
different relations to the
past pound aims to make it new,
uh, itself. I suggested a
translated phrase from the,
the ancient Chinese
pound.
In doing this aims to carry
culture forward, uh, to, uh,
you know, handed over to us as a kind
of, uh, living in immediate thing.
Uh, the past is, is
renewable, uh, in translation.
It is a communicable that
that's part of the premise of,
of translation. Um, for pound.
The past is something that
can be reembody lead, uh,
continually a needs to be reembody.
We'd continually over and over
again in new forms in this sense,
uh, translation envisions
a past that is metamorphic,
uh, and, and mobile, uh, and
durable. Uh, it, you know,
it's something that is always
essentially itself. Uh,
it's something that you know, is capable
of being carried forward. Uh, and,
and you can, you'd think about
pounds, um, voyagers who's seafarers,
a deceased or the seafarer
poet, uh, as being, um,
well agents or, or, uh, uh,
representatives of acts of
translation they embody.
Um, uh, the action of
carrying something across,
journeying in quotation, however,
uh,
the past is something to be preserved,
which is different, uh, preserved, uh,
or maybe mocked,
uh,
in the sense of mocked in the
sense of copied or parodied
quotation seems to imply to
possible relations to the past.
When you think about it,
deference to the past,
deference to what has been said
or some kind of violation of it,
uh, when you quote someone, uh,
especially maybe your
parents or a teacher, uh,
well, what are you doing? Uh,
probably, uh, you mean, uh,
either to honor them, uh, or to mock them,
right. Uh, to, uh, uh, uh,
in a sense,
defer to their authority or to
take it away, to empty it out.
Both of these are our possible, uh, uh,
empty it out by parroting it,
uh,
treating it as if it were
merely iterable and formulaic.
Uh, and therefore, uh,
without substance, uh,
Elliot quotations,
uh,
teeter a ambiguously a
between these two options.
And sometimes you may feel he's doing
the one thing and sometimes you may feel
he's doing the other,
that is somehow deferring to the past.
And honoring it,
or he's doing something quite subversive,
uh, something periodic,
uh, and, and in pound,
I don't think there's any
of that ambiguity ever. Uh,
it's a very striking a contrast.
If you listen to a pound online, uh, you,
you hear a voice, uh,
that is a fierce, uh,
in melodramatic, uh,
and, um, uh, in earnest,
uh, you listened to Elliot, you, you
hear another voice, uh, entirely, uh,
one dry diffident hard to place tonally.
Uh, this has all worked
into the poetry, uh,
in our encounters with it on the page.
Um,
again,
you might contrast the heroic
figures that you meet in pound,
uh, whether they're Odysseus or, um, uh,
troubadour poet, um, or, um,
one of the political leaders
that pound a fastens on.
These are men of will
and willpower and action.
These are the people that attract
pounds, admiration, and imagination.
Who Do you meet in
Elliot j Alfred Prufrock,
uh, this figure of, uh,
extraordinary in
decisiveness. Uh, and, uh,
um, uh, indeterminate will, uh,
someone who's diffident. Um, well,
Prufrock is surely aversion
of Elliot, uh, and, and,
uh,
we encounter in Elliot generally
some of the problems that Prufrock,
uh, raises for us, um,
through his, um, uh,
meandering, uh, mode of speech, uh,
and difficult to place tone.
Let's, um, let's look at
some pictures of Elliot. Um,
maybe my favorite one,
uh,
especially since we're going
to be thinking about and
talking about a Elliot's
age, uh, in how he, how he
projects himself. This is, uh,
this is Tom at eight. Uh, he,
he was born in Saint Louis,
the only major British poet
born in Saint Louis. Uh,
in 1888, uh, he went to Harvard. Um,
uh, this was a, uh,
uh, not a surprise, uh,
and a, a and a sense
of family mission. Um,
uh, he spent his summers, uh,
importantly in Massachusetts, uh,
and on the coast of
Massachusetts, the, uh,
north shore of Boston and these
places return and recur in his poetry,
uh, as a graduate student at Harvard. Uh,
in 1910,
he IX patriated to, uh, Europe.
Let's, this is Elliot. In 1910,
1911, he's, he had studied
philosophy at Harvard.
Um,
and he went on to study philosophy
at Cambridge with Bertrand Russell a.
He wrote his master's
thesis on Fh Bradley. Uh,
that's an association I'll say more
about when we get to the wasteland.
Uh,
in 1915,
he met and married Vivian. Hey, would,
uh,
a,
a charismatic and volatile English woman.
Uh,
this romance produced for Elliot kind of
dramatic conflict with his family over
his wish to marry her, uh, his, uh,
wish to take up residence in,
in England.
And, uh, behind all of
this and with all of this,
his sense of vocation is desire to become,
to establish himself as a poet and man
of letters rather than the more easily to
be approved. Uh, career of
a professor and scholar,
uh,
that he had seemed to have been
made for a pound was a Elliot's,
uh, older friend and mentor.
Uh, very quickly, uh,
upon there,
a meeting in Europe and pound,
uh,
always putting his fingers
in everything, uh, wrote, uh,
quite an extraordinary letter
to Elliot's father. Uh,
and I've got that on the, uh,
your handout in the top page,
a little quotation from it. Uh, it says,
it says a lot about pounds and
says something about Elliot to, uh,
this is, uh, a letter in which, um, uh,
pound felt the need to probably
with some encouragement,
but probably also some embarrassment,
uh,
from Elliott felt the need to,
um,
defend Elliot's, uh, expatriation, uh,
to the family patriarch and a pound says
as to his Elliot's coming to London.
Well, anything else is a
waste of time and energy.
No one in London cares a hang
what is written in America, uh,
after getting an American audience
and man has to begin all over again.
If he plans for an international
hearing and who wouldn't plan for an
international hearing? Uh, he,
he even begins at a disadvantage.
London likes discovering her own gods.
Again,
in alliterate career,
mediocrity is worse than useless either.
A man goes into go the whole hog,
uh,
or he had better take to selling
soap and gents furnishings. You can,
is this the right way to write Mr
Elliot? I don't know. He must've felt so,
uh, the situation has been very
well summed up in the sentence.
Henry James stayed in Paris and
red [inaudible] and flo bear.
Mr Howell's returned to
America and read Henry James
and then, and then, uh, he, he
says in the, in another, uh,
important sentence,
a literary man's income depends very
much and how rigidly he insists on doing
exactly what he himself wants to do.
It's interesting,
uh,
the idea is that by establishing
some kind of independence from,
uh,
tastes in a literary market,
Elliot will in fact
come to establish his position in that
literary market and his ability in fact,
to create taste. Uh, and,
and so in fact, he did
a, at this early point in Elliot's
career, there is a kind of, um,
important conflict between
conformity and revolt,
a conformity, uh, to, uh,
his parents wishes social
expectations were revolt from them.
Uh,
which is also,
I think another way to
describe the tension between
two different senses or were
aspects of quotation.
A pound wants Elliot's father to
see that his son's revolt is okay.
Uh, because in fact, he's
also going to conform.
He's going to conform to a certain ideal
of tradition to professional standards.
Uh, he's going to, um, uh,
he's not just going to have a wild time.
Uh,
he's going to work hard, uh,
and, and do what a literary man,
uh, should do a Elliot,
uh, you'll see, uh,
takes up these themes in different terms,
but a related ways in tradition,
in the individual talent,
which I'll talk about
later. Uh, like pound, uh,
Elliot we'll see,
wants to ally himself with tradition.
I wants to ally himself with tradition
over against their Lieber, uh,
Amy lol and Amy Chism, uh, and uh,
at the same time, um, his
relation to tradition,
even from very early on
what's potentially subversive and his
poetry was very new and disturbing.
Now, there are all sorts of interesting
things and buying a key, uh, including
here. Here he is again,
the offer of proof fraud,
including PSLE.
It's waistcoat
hds death mask. I showed you last
time. Here's, here's the, uh,
Elliot's waistcoat. Um, I
like this, uh, as an object,
uh, as, as part of, um,
uh, the literary archive.
We have, uh, also, uh,
well it's interesting, isn't it? It's a,
it's a piece of Elliot's costume.
Costume was very important for Tsla.
I think it's also a potentially a kind
of emblem of quotation in his work,
uh,
is Elliot taking on the past and the or
of propriety in order to parody it or
empower himself. Uh, these are,
these are questions we might ask
even about the waistcoat. Uh,
is it, uh, is it some kind
of disguise? Is it, uh,
uh, is it, um, uh, a, um,
costume through which he, um, uh,
conforms to social forms and expectations?
Uh,
or is it again,
something he puts on?
Uh, all of these questions
are at, uh, for me,
the center of Elliot's interest
in, in, in power, uh, and,
and also I think,
uh,
some of the lasting power
that he, uh, exerts,
um, uh, in schools, uh, and for students.
I will,
um,
I will confess that my high school
yearbook carries a quotation from Tsl,
yet in fact, from the love song of j
Alfred Prufrock, which I won't, uh,
identify for you. Uh, and
as I think about that,
why I cared about Elliot,
uh, when I was 17 or so,
um, I mean, not that I
don't now to, uh, uh,
when I think about that,
it seems to me that I'm,
his special combination of
ambition and aggression,
uh, expressed as it is
very often by young people,
uh,
through parody or satire or diffidence
was powerful for me too as a young
person. Uh, all of this is,
is I'm on display in,
in Elliot's great poem,
the love Song of J. Dot. Alfred Prufrock
or just what I'll concentrate on today.
Um,
um,
Prufrock is, uh, a poem
composed, uh, initially at Harvard
and carried with something Elliot
carried along with him, uh,
in the years, uh, after, uh,
a poem created out of
pages and pages of drafts,
which Elliot kept adding to
a and going back over and,
and recombining and recomposing them
somewhat like his repetitive and wayward
speaker. Uh, you, you, you can find, um,
uh, early versions of
the poem, uh, in, um, uh,
a book of, uh, uh,
Elliot's, uh, uh, early, uh,
and otherwise on collected work that
Christopher ricks edited a few years ago
called the inventions of the march
hare. It's a very interesting book. Uh,
and you can see Elliot,
uh,
exploring different ways
to write this poem, uh,
which hung around for a long time.
Uh,
it was eventually published
in 1915 in poetry magazine,
uh, and in this way, just like mowing a,
just like a Yates is the fishermen,
uh, which also appeared there. Then,
uh, also, uh, a poem we'll get to in
a couple of weeks, Marianne Morris,
a grave, uh, and, and some of the
images, pumps we discussed last week.
All of these, uh, appearing thanks
to pound, uh, in poetry magazine.
Uh, the poem became the title
of Elliot's first volume.
Uh, interestingly, this is
the cover of the book. Um,
uh, it leaves off or the, um, uh,
it leaves off the full title,
which was Prufrock and other observations,
uh, which is an interesting title. Uh,
first of all is Prufrock
and observation. Uh, that's,
Elliot was treating this character
as if he were an observation.
You could think about
what that might imply. Uh,
and then think about that
word observations. Uh,
it suggests something seen of course,
as well as some kind of a speculation.
Um, uh, it's also, um, uh,
a way of defining and
presenting Elliot's pumps.
He doesn't say Prufrock and other poems
he says Prufrock and other observations,
uh, in, in observations
is in fact, uh, then, uh,
a word that,
that Marianne Moore would use to title
her first book of poems a few years later.
Uh, on that cover, uh,
we see Elliott's name and Prufrock's,
uh,
in some kind of a alteration,
alternation rather, uh, Prufrock being
a little bit bigger than TSL yet.
Uh,
but I'm raising for us
graphically the simple question,
what is the relationship
between these two? Uh,
uh, are they, uh, yeah, uh,
the one man created the
other thing, uh, Prufrock uh,
are they the same thing?
How different are they? Uh,
here, um, uh, the, uh, uh,
interior of the book. Uh, you can
see, although, well you can't see,
but if you get a better look at this
online, you will see, uh, that this book,
which is in buying a key, uh, it
has a signature on it. Wu Steven's,
uh, and why? Uh, October 17th, 1917.
So this is, this was Stephen's copy, uh,
at which he as he was a young man
wandering around the streets of New York,
uh, picked up, uh, and, and kept. Um,
it was, uh, like a frosts early, uh,
work published in London in 1917 now,
um, in, in Bloomsbury by
the egoist pressed. Uh,
and there's the table of
contents. Um, the, uh,
first and long poem,
uh,
included in the volume being the
love song of j Alfred Prufrock.
Well,
what do we expect from a poem that
calls itself that the love Song of J.
Dot. Alfred Prufrock. Uh, first of
all, what do we expect from this genre?
The love Song, a love song. What is a
love song? What is it love song? Like,
presumably it would be a romantic poem.
Uh,
even a poem about romance. Uh, uh,
what we get is perhaps something more
like a parody of a romantic palm,
uh, and something much stranger.
Uh, this is going to be
familiar to very many of you.
Let us go.
Then you and I,
when the evening is spread out
against the sky, like a patient,
he theorized upon a table,
let us go through certain
half deserted streets,
the muttering retreats of restless nights
and one night cheap hotels and sought
us restaurants with oyster shells,
streets that follow like a
tedious argument of insidious
intent to lead you to
an overwhelming question. Oh, do not ask,
what is it?
Let us go and make our visit
in the room. The women come
and go. Talking of Michelangelo
cool
meter.
Uh,
it's a topic we've, we've
raised before. It isn't,
uh, I am the pentameter. Um, the, uh,
it's notably importantly
not I ambit pentameter. Uh,
instead,
uh,
you are introduced to another
kind of rhythm of speech,
which you can work at to scan a,
but without even going
into any detail about it,
I think we can describe
that rhythm is Languid, uh,
as open to variation, uh, as,
um,
including hesitancy and
sometimes abruptness.
Uh, it is, uh,
a way of speaking that
is interrupted often,
uh, is, uh, alternately, um, uh,
voluble, uh, and nervous, uh,
the, um, uh, the poems,
initial disc continuity's of rhythm
and pattern and image introduce us to,
um,
really a new kind of structure
in poetry that would include,
um, well, uh, kind of, um,
uh, almost, uh, almost a principle
that anytime you establish a pattern,
you must quickly break it.
Uh, let us go. Then you and I,
when the evening is spread
out against the sky,
sounds like this character is going to
speak in couplets like a patient ether
rised upon a table. Where
did that come from? Uh,
uh, let us, you know, we could
supply another third line. Uh, uh,
uh, uh, that would be a
very different, I think, um,
immediately we are invited to, um, well,
uh, realistically conjure, um,
a prone, uh, patient, um,
uh, someone, uh, someone sick, uh,
and being attended to and ether
rised unconscious, uh, uh,
an objectified, uh, uh,
upon a table. Uh, if,
if, um, we felt as though
we were going to be in, um,
a romantic crepuscular atmosphere,
uh,
we are suddenly confronted
with an image quite disturbing,
uh, and ugly and note
that it doesn't rhyme. Uh,
there,
I suppose you could,
you could connect table to
hotels and shells below. Um,
but, uh, it's not, uh, a
strong connection and, um,
there has been, uh, no, um,
uh, preparation for it before.
Uh, so immediately we are
given an image, uh, and, uh,
a rhyme decision if you like,
uh,
that complicates any kind of sense of
a pattern that we might have predicted
from the first two lines. That rhythm. Um,
well, um, uh,
the contrast to a Nim big poem, uh, is,
is strong and should be emphasized.
And I want to draw your
attention to, um, uh,
an example that would have been in
the ears of Elliot's listeners. Uh,
and that is a, the Elliot's listeners
Elliot's readers, that is, um,
uh, the end of a Tennyson's Ulysses, um,
a poem well known in the 19th century,
the long day wanes.
The slow moon climbs the deep
moans round with many voices.
I quote it too because,
uh,
Elliot love this passage and it
returns in his late poetry, uh, in, um,
uh,
interesting echoes come my friends.
Tis Not too late to seek a newer world.
It may be that the
gulfs will wash us down.
It may be we shall touch the happy isles
and see the Great Achilles whom we knew
though much is taken, much abides. And
though we are not now that strength,
which in old days moved
earth and heaven were older,
that which we are,
we are one equal temper of heroic
hearts made weak by time and fate,
but strong in will to strive, to
seek, to find and not to yield.
Where uh, echoing I think, uh, Milton's,
Satan, uh, the, uh, the blank
verse suddenly, you know,
becomes a kind of heroic
medium of the will. Uh,
well the contrast is important,
uh,
with the poetry that Elliot
is presenting to us, uh,
because here, uh, the
question of the speakers will,
is so much at issue and his manner of
speech is so different from the example
that Tennyson gives us
a Tennyson specifically in this
dramatic monologue as in others,
uh, of, uh, his, uh,
erv or other important 19th
century examples introduces
us to a dramatic speaker
who has a kind of coherent
character, uh, and, and, uh,
um, uh, who's unity of
character, if you like,
uh, is allied to the unity
of the verse form itself.
Elliot gives us something very different.
Uh,
he creates in frog,
I would say not a character,
rather,
he creates something more
like a consciousness. Uh,
he creates a, uh,
a fragmentary consciousness,
uh,
that rises and falls,
take shape and disperses before us.
John Stuart Mill said,
uh, in, in, uh, memorable,
uh,
passage that poetry lyric poetry is what
he was thinking of is overheard speech,
overheard speech. Well, and you can think,
uh, if you have some sense of, uh,
the romantic poetry of
Wordsworth, uh, or, or, um,
uh,
Coleridge as examples before you
have of what mill had in mind,
the way in which in those poems
we listened in on, um, uh,
uh, soliloquies, ing, uh, poets, thoughts,
listening to Prufrock is much less like
listening to someone speak on the street
or on the stage,
uh,
than it is like closing
your eyes and remembering,
uh,
or inventing voices in your mind.
Elliot is creating a kind
of overheard inner speech.
Uh, he's, he's, uh,
he's letting us listen in on a mind,
uh,
that we don't see whole.
We don't feel whole. Uh,
we only get parts of it,
uh, fluctuation. Uh,
this is the,
this is the medium and the rhythm,
uh,
that, uh, we, we entered
when we entered the poem.
Uh, there is, uh, as I
was already suggesting,
no overarching pattern
for the poems verse form.
Um, I think this is probably
true for, uh, other, uh,
dimensions of organization,
uh, as well. Um,
there are rather,
uh,
in this poem what I would call a kind
of set of unfolding local systems of
organization. Um, there are, uh, couplets.
We see couplets in that first paragraph,
but then they're not
systematically pursued. Um,
instead what you get in the
poem or a lot of loose ends,
uh,
pauses a bits and pieces of language,
a language that is almost
always full of quotations,
which your editor will give you,
uh, the source for some of them.
Uh, what we have then in the poem as he
moved through it as though it's a lot of
shifting improvised orders,
uh,
this formal instability
in the palm is related to,
and it constructs a
special sort of speaker,
a one who is performing for us,
uh, his, his thoughts,
his thoughts, uh, experienced as a
set of routines or rifts or acts.
Uh,
and they come and go without a
very definite aim or conclusion.
Looking at the cover of,
of Prufrock,
I asked you to think about
the relationship between
Prufrock and ts. Eliot,
uh,
you think you can think about,
Prufrock the name itself,
Jay Alfred Prufrock,
almost a kind of parody of t s Elliott.
Um,
the, the name suggests a
kind of upper class, uh,
English or Anglo file person.
Uh,
those formal initials are, are,
uh, uh, pretentious in a way.
Um,
I think it's proper to think of Prufrock
as in some sense a kind of comic
figure,
a almost like a cartoon
or a caricature or device.
Um,
on one level a,
he is a kind of parody
of a romantic singer.
Uh, he is bourgeois. He
is intellectualizing, uh,
he's incapable of grasping and expressing
what we expect from a love song that
is strong emotion.
Uh,
the poem can be seen to as a,
as a kind of critique
of romantic egotism and,
uh, of the Wordsworthian ideal
of, of expression. This is,
uh, something that, uh,
Elliot a theorizes polemically,
uh, in his essay, uh,
tradition and the individual
talent. Uh, and in fact,
why don't we look there for a few minutes
to get more sense of a Elliot's ideas.
Uh, nine 46 at the back
of your book there. Uh,
he says,
I'm quoting Wordsworth in the
preface to lyrical ballads.
We must believe that emotion
recollected in tranquility is an exam,
is an inexact formula for it as
neither emotion nor recollection,
nor without distortion of meaning
tranquility that you get in in Eliot poem.
At least it is a concentration and a new
thing resulting from the concentration
of a very great number of experiences,
which to the practical inactive person
would not seem to be experienced as it
all.
It is the concentration which does not
happen consciously or of deliberation.
Uh,
these experiences are not recollected.
Okay.
And they finally United in an atmosphere
which is tranquil only and that it is a
passive attending upon the event.
There's a,
Eliot is trying to describe poetry here
as having a kind of generating a kind of
experience in and of itself that is
distinct from any kind of recollected
experience.
Uh,
and it is curiously impersonal
as he imagines that.
And he continues and there's a
great deal in the writing of poetry,
which must be conscious and deliberate.
In fact,
the bad poet is usually unconscious where
he ought to be conscious and conscious
where he ought to be unconscious.
We know what he means. Uh,
both errors tend to make him
personal and am now Tsla.
It will say poetry is not
a turning loose of emotion,
but an escape from emotion.
It is not the expression of personality,
but an escape from personality.
But of course,
only those who have personality and
emotions know what it means to want to
escape from these things.
Uh,
which is a extraordinary
kind of Coda to this, uh,
polemical passage.
Okay.
Ah, and, and revealing of course,
uh, the, the way in which Elliot,
even as he's polemicizing
against a romantic poetry
that would be too personal,
uh, is deeply invested in, uh,
the personal, uh, and personality,
uh, and conflicted about it. Uh,
I've been,
uh,
talking about ambiguity in Elliot. Um, uh,
well we can speak of ambivalence,
uh,
this essay a retains even while it is
critiquing a certain romantic story of,
of creation.
Uh,
and we could say something similar
about Elliot's Love Song Prufrock,
uh,
is a kind of pretext or a device through
which Elliot can speak of himself.
Uh,
Prufrock becomes a way of
writing the self when to Elliot.
It no longer seems plausible
to write as oneself
as a Wordsworth had felt it to be.
You can think of Prufrock as a,
as a kind of mask behind which you hear
a young poet asking questions about
himself and his art.
A list,
the poems, questions there.
Prufrock asks questions throughout.
Uh, do you recall them?
They are. Do I dare?
Do I dare disturb the universe?
So how should I presume?
And how should I begin?
Shall I say?
He says that pretty often.
Shall I say this?
Shall I say that
daring presuming beginning,
what shall I say?
These are,
are they not an ambitious young poets?
Questions about how to write poetry.
The question is,
why should beginning be something
that you really have to dare?
Uh, what does that imply? Uh,
why should it be frightening?
Why should it give you pause in y if
these are a young man's questions as I'm
suggesting,
does Prufrock seem as old
as old and weary as he does?
In fact,
how old do you think he is?
I don't know. Uh, ask
yourselves that question. Uh,
ask yourselves what evidence you
would have for one answer. Another.
Uh, it's hard to pinpoint
his age. Prufrock is,
isn't he a kind of old young man
or young old man?
Uh,
he is cautious and
aggressive at the same time.
Uh,
old and young.
These paradoxes I think point
to Elliot's sense of his place,
his own place in literary history,
in some sense of what it meant
to be modern for Elliot. Uh,
Prufrock is burdened by the question
of how to begin in dd begins exactly by
deferring beginning a by failing to
come to the point by putting it off,
by delaying.
Because by implication,
beginning is indeed something threatening,
something that must be dared.
But this only makes sense if Prufrock
really does want to disturb the universe
or at least the system of
culture as he found it.
It only makes sense of beginning
really does require disturbing things.
Uh,
the implication is that the universe
is already complete without Prufrock,
without Tsa,
Elliot and anything
that he might do or say,
you can extend this to
Elliot's idea of culture. Uh,
and in particular to his sense
of the literary past, uh,
you see the idea in tradition,
in the individual talent, uh, uh,
nine 42,
nine 43,
he speaks of a, towards the
bottom of the page on nine 42, uh,
tradition as a kind of
ideal order of monuments.
Tradition is in some sense,
well,
it's monumental and it's already
complete as he imagines it to add to it,
to enter,
it would be to change it to disturb it.
Uh,
in fact,
Elliot evolves here a quite ingenious
and complicated argument for how the new
could indeed be introduced to a
tradition conceived in the terms I just
described. Elliot says, uh, on
the bottom of the page about,
uh, the, uh, any, any new poet,
the necessity that he shall conform.
And there's that word conform.
Think of the waistcoat,
the necessity that he shall conform,
that he shall cohere and remain
put together is not one sided.
This was quite an extraordinary argument.
He's saying
it's not only necessary for a new poet
too, in a sense, conform to tradition.
What happens when a new work of art is
created as something that's happened
simultaneously to all the works of art,
which proceeded it.
Something which happens simultaneously
to all the works of art,
which proceeded it.
This is quite a claim.
The existing monuments form an
ideal order among themselves,
which is modified by the
introduction of the new,
the really new work of art among them.
The existing orders complete before the
new work arrives for order to present,
persist after the Super
Vientiane of novelty.
Novelty comes as something
that supervenes it has force,
it's a leopard and the temple.
The whole existing order must
be if ever so slightly altered.
And so the relations,
proportions values of each work of art
toward the whole a readjusted and this is
conformity between the old
and the new. It's, uh, uh,
here Elliot is,
is struggling with,
with an idea of tradition as something
that is static and, and fully,
uh,
present in and of itself a sense of the
new as something that is revolutionary,
uh, and that threatens tradition
or is threatened by it.
How can he bring them into alignment?
Well,
through this very complicated
process, uh, that he describes,
which, uh, gives the
modern, gives the new, um,
okay,
an extraordinary power to make us see and
in fact to realign the relations among
all the works of the past.
Okay.
And this is, uh, uh, as I say,
quite an extraordinary power.
Uh,
the implication is the new poet must in
some sense rest authority from all those
who have come before through a kind of
imaginative and rhetorical violence,
uh, kind of, uh, insurrection
in, in the temple of culture.
Prufrock's sense of age,
uh,
expresses for him a feeling of relatedness
and anxiety that he's already a run
out of time is very youth.
The fact that it's the only
just now starting makes him old,
uh,
to presume would be to reverse this order,
to dare to come before
and to claim priority, uh,
for his own work. Uh, as
I say these sentences,
I sound a whole lot like Harold
bloom, uh, as, uh, uh, he,
uh, describes, uh, the,
uh, uh, mission of any,
uh, poet in his work on
the anxiety of influence.
And that is because a Bloom's work is a
deeply indebted precisely to Elliot and
to tradition and the individual
talent. But these are questions, uh,
I'll say a little bit more
about, um, uh, next time, uh,
as we, uh, uh,
finish discussing
Elliott's a love song and,
uh, begin to, uh, talk
about the wasteland.